is Reggie Miller here Polly is there
tight looking clean he's always looking
great is a big introduction here for
Reggie Miller wait is he waiting for the
the band or do we need the theme from
Dan can't do we have any music for
Reggie when he comes from role and now
[Music]
to UCLA six foot six Hall of Famer six
foot six
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah reg looking good going on no sleep
little red eye in from LA last night and
it wouldn't be so bad
Thank You Lionsgate for getting us a g5
which was cool very cool
thank you Lionsgate ankle Dru who's on
the plane just me and Shaq and his crew
and it wouldn't I love I love the Shaq
don't get me wrong but you know Shaq's a
DJ now right he does all these clubs
he's yeah he's a regular DJ he's so he
was practicing the whole flight here you
know that people have that portable the
ones and twos oh my god let's leave do
you have to balance the plane like Shaq
is on one side of the valley how do how
does she fit on this plan it was a very
comfortable oh yeah it was good Thank
You Lionsgate yeah so reg is here
Lionsgate releasing uncle drew starting
a reg c-webb Kyrie Shak Nate Robinson
Lisa Leslie the world premiere the film
is tonight in New York City is OK does
the ending bring about the possibility
of a sequel it does because basketball
you can always continue to move on
there could be uncle Drude 20 it could
be like one of the Rocky movies okay
does anybody die in this movie close
whoo close whoo there's somebody have
like a heart attack or something maybe
stealin amazing baby who's the best
actor out of the NBA players Kyrie has
been doing this his uncle drew character
for a while so it wasn't a stretch of
the imagination for him to act old the
person we
coming in here neck c-webb phenomenal
really phenomenal could see web be an
actor how many six ten actors are there
not many okay not many so he would be an
outlier yeah yeah he was phenomenal
would he be the 610 Denzel Washington no
he's Denzel and I'm Daniel day-lewis we
are a great combo we are a great combo
well it was there an after party last
night
after the NBA Awards there was that
there was no time you guys left I was on
a bird cuz I wanted to come here and see
my Dan ya know it's called it you were
all dead they were on a PGA it's called
a PGA it's called the PJ private gym oh
it's a pjju to private ok yes private
yeah yeah you know James Harden's award
you know when he won I thought he was
great he had to drop the mic there I'll
see you next year it was great but the
outfit when you saw the outfit with
James Hart not just James Harden though
there was a lot of outfits ok did you
shake your head ok best one worst one
would you have taken away the MVP from
James oh I was seriously thinking about
recounting the votes by looking out his
outfit don't you think it looked like I
did again why do people wear shades
inside you know we know he has 20 20 20
15 bitching why are you wearing shades
to accept your MVP well the lights are
brutal come on now and we want to see
you look if you're gonna get up there
and bubble up and you know talk about
your you know mama we want to see the
teachers don't we we want to see the
tears don't you think it looks like that
chick-fil-a billboard it like you like
it looks like the cow like eat more
chicken like that's what it looked like
you never have to see James Harden you
throw darts from the studio not afraid
to change you'll never see J if James
came in I'd say I guarantee I guarantee
I would guarantee that his outfit look
like the chick-fil-a cow yeah ok
here's an idea have for it this is this
a great idea it didn't catch on
yesterday maybe it catches on today
here's how LeBron makes his announcement
alright are you ready okay so he has his
show he has his own website yes so he's
got the shot he's sitting there in the
barbershop chair at the barber there
okay
all of a sudden barber says you want to
see what see what it looks like so he
spins and he's got L an A in his haircut
and then you spin him back around and
then you have a big smile and then you
fade to black and that's it
it could be the clips could be the
length of the Lakers or if it just says
you know CL e for Cleveland right and
you have all the people going to his
website and then you you know more
details coming you think like he really
needs more traffic - yes I'm sure he
controls the message didn't he control
the message from the decision yeah and
we saw how that well ESPN ESPN
controlled that because they dragged it
out an hour if he showed up and had the
decision where he just said you know Jim
Gray says all right so where are you
going anyways lost though it's the Boys
and Girls Club he did a great day a
great job for the boys and girls but not
in Greenwich Connecticut matter where
the Boys and Girls Clubs are there's I
mean one was benefiting from yeah they
got more lacrosse sticks and
Oh baby over here I got baby trouble Wow
Wow kidding me Wow
now you want to separate kids that's why
I'm over here and they're over there
that's how I separated me from the kids
oh all right so the big movie premiere
tonight we'll come back with red Jesse
Webb will join us as well for more Dan
Patrick show to the audience Channel 239
on DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick
show app
[Music]